hallo mein name ist lokal herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video von
nintendo kirche zusammen mit balu den
geht's eigentlich sogar den gibt's ja
echt richtig cool eigentlich der plan
für die heutige folge ist dass ich mit
ihm zusammen spazieren gehen werde dort
vielleicht das ein oder andere geschenk
noch aufgaben werde und dass dann alles
nach dem secondhand laden verkaufen
werde und mir dann nachher versuche
einen neuen hund zu kaufen gerade macht
keinen spaziergang
dann will man geschenke finden antrieb
vermutet bruder hundebesitzer ich bin
ehrlich mit euch ich wollte tatsächlich
schicken schon mal weil ich gedacht habe
ich brauche geld
im real life hat das nicht so alles ganz
gut geklappt in den tender
was soll da fällt weil du einmal von
einer schulter runter da macht die
rechte bahn oder direkt freunde darauf
wieder der emilia balu fühlt sich nach
dem spiel mit capo großartig
sie muss halt nicht wie ich an geld
kommen soll deswegen habe ich gedacht
dass ich da dann einfach
ach du meine güte man das ist doch nicht
wahr wie kannst du denn immer scheiße
man aber dann haben wir wieder eine
klare gestehen dass sich sein
wenn du das gemacht hat ist also wie
lahm in die kommentare geschrieben dass
ich sachen die ich finde im secondhand
laden verkaufen kann und hast du ein
geschenk ich will die schenke wenn du
geld sparen willst könntest du nötige
gegenstände im second händlern verkaufen
das licher machen aber dann kommst du
mit deinem scheiß pupsi david balu sind
einfach irgendein geschenk auf dem weg
da irgendwas sinnvoll ist und was ist
jetzt sind wir haben nichts gefunden ich
geh jetzt einfach mal einen secondhand
laden und schau mal dass ich da mal ein
tennisball zwei euro bekomme ich da nur
für also die sachen die ich bisher
gefunden haben waren ja ein hunde foto
und eine sektflasche für dieser flasche
bekomme ich 80 cent und für das hunde
foto 2 euro
vielleicht wird das hat doch nichts mit
dem neuen hund ich gehe jetzt mal in den
zwinger und schauen ob ich mir ein hund
kaufen kann aber die sind ja alle so
fucking teuer die kosten mindestens
irgendwie 535 ich habe 400 weinmann
nächste runde noch definitiv im
zwergpudel werden da hätte ich ihn
gerichtet so ein zwerg 595
bei ruhig bleibt erst mal bei dir
alleine welche ideen hab dich in dem ddp
damit so heißt der e motor wie ich
dagegen kann oder wie ich geld kriege
dann schreibt mir das bitte
dann will ich an einem plug-in
wettbewerb teilnehmen dann kommt du
kannst teilnehmen nachdem du in der
sporthalle trainiert hast warum ich habe
ja letzten schon mit balu ein bisschen
mit disk trainiert deswegen machen wird
ja das ist ja toll was du hier wieder
alles kann ich das irgendwie
überspringen hier ich brauche fünf
punkte weil du bitte enttäuscht mich
nicht zum korb wieso denkt 7,00 auf weg
und im sprung 0 punkte sind die
bescheuerte anfang mit dir kann man
nicht arbeiten kommen wenigstens einen
punkt meine fresse das ist doch nicht
war mit denen kann man nichts anfangen
während die dabei intern dogs gerade
verkünden wer aktuell gewonnen hat
manchmal das sechs natürlich in meinem
tollen adventskalender auf natürlich
hätte ich machen jungs adventskalender
kaufen kann ich hab aber ich bin gerade
beim zu gefahren aber ich fand so ein
bisschen witziger und wir haben diesmal
drin einen neuen dress
sollte ich eigentlich wissen dass die
gravitation das runterzieht das ist
adrian vor der tollen dress umwandlung
die ich jetzt mache und das ist serien
nach der tollen dress umwandlung
sie sieht tatsächlich aus wie ein neuer
mensch mit diesen anderen sachen ja
freunde das natürlich in sechs von
trends gelände haben im morgigen video
mache ich wieder irgendwas auf und
schaltet wieder ein einem ergebnis von 0
punkten und schafft es somit nicht aufs
podest pech gehabt aber ich verstehe
dich er zweimal gefangen das sind doch
eigentlich zwei punkte es wäre
vielleicht eine gute idee trainings buch
zu lesen
der typ sieht aus wie seine frau und der
sieht aus wie eine mülltonne mit diesen
beiden blöd wir sind wieder zu hause
angekommen ich dachte wirklich erst der
plan wäre gewesen dass sich quasi in der
runde spazieren gehe da noch irgendwie
23 geschenke mit nehme dann wie gar
nicht sagt händler verkaufen nach
irgendwie 530 euro oder so zusammen hat
und mir neuen hund kaufen kann das war
der grobe plan und jetzt hab ich halt
gedacht dass sie noch ein diss
wettbewerb machen wo ich vielleicht
gewinne weil ich mit balu ja schon mal
trainieren war aber der typ ist so
unfähig hier wenn euch das video
trotzdem gefallen hat würden wir und ich
uns beide das passiert ca pro folge 20